[Music]
what an ending to Hollywood's biggest
night you guys we are here to talk about
the Oscars especially that now
unforgettable ending that we all just
watched I'm Lauren Zima I'm Ashley
Carlson and I'm Deidre Vega
ashley is very blown away very highly
yes you guys so the Oscars just ended
and if you've missed it the wrong movie
was called for the Best Picture winner
it was announced as lala land but the
actual Best Picture winner was moonlight
we lost by the way but you know there's
a mistake moonlight you guys won Best
Picture this is not a joke I'm afraid
they read the wrong thing this is not a
joke moonlight is won Best Picture
moonlight this picture
so crazy so to explain briefly what you
guys just saw was the cast and crew of
lala land had come up to accept the
award and then a stage manager came out
on stage Warren Beatty and Faye Dunaway
were on stage to announce the Best
Picture winner lala land people come up
stage manager then comes out and
seemingly communicates that the wrong
name was read off the card I mean I mean
you could see when they were they were
giving full acceptance speeches by the
way they got really far in their
acceptance speeches and you could see
the stage manager kind of rustling
around in the background and somebody in
the office even called but out there
what's happening in the background you
can feel this commotion happening and
then all of a sudden he was like we lost
by the way he's in the very tense yeah
no doubt I'm still sitting here trying
to process it in my brain and like you
just said yeah I don't know what I'm
saying I'm like I have anxiety and you
know I understand there's this whole
like argument of it's just an award show
let it go live TV things happen but I
was just telling you in the dressing
room before this is the Oscars you get
one shot hopefully one shot in your life
to go up there to say what you mean mean
what you say and and earn your award and
I feel like it was wrongfully you know
just taken away from them when they
thought that they had already had that
glimmer of glory we were talking I don't
think this I can't remember certainly
this ever happening in the history of
the Academy Award no I mean we just Miss
Universe yeah the summon was Steve
Harvey yeah and you know what I did
appreciate about the whoever was behind
the camera that was that they zoomed in
because at that point you really have to
show people no moonlight is on the car I
didn't know I was like are they pulling
like the Adele where they're like no
we're not taking we can't accept this
it's moonlight interest I originally
thought that was happening for like a
split second until they actually showed
shattered I mean I think we have to just
take a minute to give kudos to Jimmy
Kimmel who really I think thrived yes of
the moment and he was so
self-deprecating and just blamed it on
himself and was like I'm never coming
back this is all my fault
obviously it had nothing to do yet he
said I knew I would screw the show I
could serve this up and you know and I
have to give all so kudos to Warren
Beatty who I think kind of handled it
very elegantly he did not intend on
standing up there and explaining himself
in this whole momentum but you could see
that you know when he was looking down
at the card there was something you know
the wheels were spinning something
didn't feel right right we were all kind
of wondering because Warren Beatty and
Faye Dunaway were up
there you know co-stars and Bonnie and
Clyde and they kind of looked at each
other for a second as Warren was opening
the card and we all thought why are they
staring at each other in silence I just
say it Warren right and then seemingly
what happened which Warren explained
after the la-la-land guy said no
moonlight you one get up here seemingly
what happened is that at some point the
envelopes might have gotten switched
Warren said that he was confused because
he looked at the envelope and saw Emma
Stone la-la-land
and she had just won for Best Actress
right and so I get assumed they just
then read la-la-land
him and Fay done it was crazy you know I
guess if there's any sort of silver
lining in all of this it's that Damien
Chazelle won I'm a stone one they got a
chance to speak their piece why no no
I'm just saying they could win a lot yes
they did so we can't take that away I
think I think it was kind of a magical
moment for moonlight Barry Jenkins did
such an eloquent amazing job speaking in
that moment certainly not the
circumstances he thought he'd ever
accept that award under its Hollywood's
biggest night it's the end to awards
season I don't you know though I will
say this is a moment we will not forget
no live TV really a wild moment you guys
that list should be nominated a really
cute moment do you want to take us
through his stuff but tell Andrew
Garfield thing Ashleigh Patel he didn't
take me as his date he took his mom
instead but it's okay I have work to do
but also subbing in for me as Andrew
Garfield there's this moment they had
where they just like really longingly
looked into each other's eyes I mean do
we have a peak of that moment oh my gosh
yes I mean love talent this is
connecting at first I thought this was
gonna be the viral moment of the night
obviously the ending is probably eclipse
tit but the tour bus gags oh so good
Jimmy Kimmel brings these regular Joe's
regular folks out into the Oscars room
and Gary went viral under the stars Oh
Gary there's a star Gary's a star he and
his fiancee potentially being married by
Denzel Washington July 19th wedding I
mean
imagine coming to LA booking your trip
and then this being me okay
right away they just walk them in there
without telling them where to go this
your own yeah these people had no idea
so that means she'd Gary there with the
purple the purple phone case just taking
selfies with everybody Jimmy's like you
can put your phone away like this is
right but the best is when he Jimmy
starts to introduce him to all the
actors he just Gary goes for it grabs
him kisses her hand handed his phone to
my Hershel ollie and says here take a
picture of me with your Oscar oh my god
I think I feel like Ellen DeGeneres did
set the bar a couple years ago and she
hosted and she took that selfie and she
delivered pizzas and so now hosts awards
shows they're like how can I do
something really different but this I
love Tracy who is amazing should we just
ended on one of our favorite couples
John Legend and Chrissy team I love them
oh my god she was like sleeping
throughout the show my god me up you
guys it will look for that it means
people took screenshots of Chrissy's
seemingly sleeping John we were
interviewing them on et's platform of
course let's take a listen to this clip
with Chrissy and John you stepped on
your wife's dress this dress will be
stepped on at least 30 times Simone you
gotta be careful good and it's not a
plan but it's a prediction I thought
maybe it was a plan because look at that
slit if you step on it too much you know
whatever
what was the react when you you're like
honey you're stepping on my dress what
do you say to him oh it's been 11 years
funny hot talented triple threat that's
what you got
you